what's going on everybody welcome to
part 19 of our intermediate Python
series in this video and the kind of
coming videos we're gonna be talking
about basically one very broadly how
everything in Python is object oriented
so whether or not you're writing
object-oriented programming code whether
or not you're writing a class or
whatever everything you're doing is an
object and you're dealing with objects
but more specifically in this one and
for sure the next tutorial we're gonna
be talking about the a special method or
a magic method and even more
specifically operator overloading so
this is the code that we're starting
with it's basically the same thing that
we've been building up to this point
although I did make a couple of changes
I'll go over them in a moment but I'm
just gonna say where you can get the
code you can go to Python programming
net come down to the fundamentals here
and then in the intermediate Python
series you can click on that come down
to part 18 it'll be after or 19 rather
it'll be after decorators it's not up
there yet because I haven't done it I'm
filming it so anyway it'll be there
though and you can click that and you
can copy and paste the code if you want
or you can make the changes there very
subtle and small really all I did
majorly was add green blob so add a
class for green blob it inherits from
blob which we already discussed but the
other thing I did was remove passing of
color that was kind of silly to pass a
color to the blue blob class it should
just be called the color blue all the
time so that's kind of stupid so what
I've done here is just hard-coded that
color again you could also pass a
constant I just chose not to for
inheritance sake just in case you wanted
to import this or something anyway yeah
when we passed it here we're not passing
a color so it made those small changes
and now with green blob we are calling
green blob here we can run it and we get
D blobs as expected
cool now what I want to do is begin
adding interaction between these blob
jects
anyway and what I'd like to be able to
do is say okay when a great Oh blue and
a red blob come into contact wouldn't it
be nice if we could just say let's say
you've got a blue blob that's a blue
blob object variable name for now and
then you've got a red blob object
wouldn't it be cool if we could just say
like plus right because this was really
happening they're combining the they're
banging into each other we want to be
able to use plus okay so that's what
we're gonna do and when we do that we're
gonna have to define a method that will
handle that that it that some that add
operation and to do that we're gonna use
that's gonna be that's a form of
operator overloading you can overload
all of the operators that you could
possibly use assignment operators
comparison operators and so on okay you
can overload all of them you can also
overload obviously the plus the minus
the multiplication and division all of
them you can overload all of them today
we're just gonna do the plus sign and
what's cool is as you'll see the way
that we do it is it's it'll be unlike
any other method it's just it's just
it's cool so anyways let's get started
so to do it it's a magic method a
special method
it's dunder add so define dunder add as
always we have to pass self but when you
have an ADD operation you're adding you
know you've got one thing plus something
else it'll be that second parameter or
whatever that is and that in our case
should be another blog right you're
gonna add blobs together in theory it
could be something else but for now
let's just say it's a blob
great so now basically it could be any
of a handful of blobs right right it
could be a red blob a green blob or a
blue blob so we need to handle for each
of those it also you know in case it's
none of those because maybe someone
doesn't understand how to properly use
this this method so so let's do that so
let's say if other blob
equals and let's say let's start if it's
a red a red block so 2 3 5 0 0 if it is
that we're gonna say self dot size minus
equals other blob dot size and then
whereas a other blob that size minus
equals self that size so in this case
self is the blue blob because this is
pertaining to the blue block size we're
not gonna add an add method to any of
the other classes it's unnecessary we
don't need to eventually you might but
the the protagonist of our blob story is
just the blue blob like that's the main
character okay so that's really who we
care about the other ones you could say
you might have a scenario where the
green blobs need to be able to be added
to red blobs and we need to figure out
how to heal that we're just not going to
handle that because we're just going to
say green blobs don't interact with red
blobs they only interact with blue blobs
and red blobs don't interact with green
blobs and so on
it's just interaction with the blue blob
so in this case just to be absolutely
clear it's not really specific to this
method but when you do something like
this like keep in mind that self that
size is being modified in place here
well not totally in place but sort of
and once you've done that then we're
subtracting size so we're not
subtracting the original size of that
blob when they came into contact we're
actually subtracting that size after
we've subtracted the size of the red
blob so really if the red blob is larger
than the blue blob it's lights out for
the blue blob and he's not really gonna
do any damage to the red blood so keep
that in mind
and in fact it might but it could even
add to the size anyway you want to think
about these things we're trying to make
just a really simple method here so I'm
gonna keep it the way it is but just
know this might not actually be what you
intend to do so pay attention to little
subtleties like that okay
so anyway oh if other blob color and in
this case what if it's green
well if it's green we're gonna say self
dot size plus equals other blob dot size
no problem and then we're gonna say
other blob dot size equals zero that's
it for green now we need to handle if
it's a blue blob so we might say other
blog color and then 0 0 255 if this is
the case for now we're gonna pass we're
just gonna say right now blue blobs
don't do anything with each other now if
none of these are hit someone obviously
passes a color that isn't one of these
three colors so if that's the case we're
gonna say else and we're gonna raise an
exception and the exception is going to
say try to combine one or multiple bombs
of unsupported colors okay so that is
our dunder add method and now we're
ready to add blobs we can already do it
but now we actually need to have some
sort of logic that is going to actually
add these blobs but you you could you
could add them so let me see where are
we actually so we created we're creating
them here
I just want to real quickly show you a
blob getting rich I'm just gonna comment
this out you can either follow this or
just watch if you want so we've got
green blobs and blue blobs so now we can
say is blue blobs and their IDs will be
or their keys or just numbers so we'll
just say blue blobs zero plus let's do
blue blobs zero plus red blobs zero so
we're gonna say they bloom they both
come into contact first we're gonna say
as well blue blob size
bread size format and now let's take
this blue blobs this is supposed to be
red both change that and also it needs
to be about size
blue blob zero and then red blobs zero
that's some size and then we'll just
copy paste and we should see the change
right so this is black just because
we've never displayed anything but here
is whoops here is the original
information the blue was a sixth the red
is a seven it was subtract seven was
subtracted from six boom you got
negative one and red ended up gaining a
size because of what we actually caught
before so if blue is a negative size you
subtract a negative that's adding so it
actually got a little bigger so it
consumed a blue a little bit so anyway
that's how it works
we can see it worked on those on the
objects but we need to come up with code
that will Lodge eclis do this rather
than just doing it as we explicitly call
it so we actually need to come up with
code that will detect when two blobs
have collided so that's what we're going
to be doing in the next tutorial is
actually detecting that collision if you
have any questions comments concerns
whatever up to this point feel free to
leave them below otherwise I'll see you
in the next tutorial